let me guess your home it was hey
everybody its charlie I always get a lot
of questions about who's the next big
villain is going to be during Marvel
phase four and there are a couple big
options but because they're going with
eternals as this sort of new IP that
they're trying to develop it also
implies that a big possibility is stuff
that they're lining up in the comics
right now if you didn't know the people
that lived on the planet Titan like he
talks about during this clip were
Eternals so Thanos his parents were
eternals making him the first real
eternal that we met in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so if you haven't
been reading the comics I'll explain how
they've changed some of the backstory
for the Eternals in what it changes
about the true history of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe going back billions
of years so that's one of the cool
things about the Eternals I did a video
a little while ago talking about how
Kevin Feige was teasing more phase for
eternal stuff he said that you know it's
basically these characters that inspire
myths and legends they live in the
mountains of Olympia in Greece so that
gives you a good idea if you're finding
me for the first time there is a new
round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video I named a new winner at the
end of this the crazy thing here is that
what we used to think is that the
Eternals were created by the Celestials
as a sort of grand cosmic experiment to
shepherd the earth and sort of help them
develop while they were doing that the
Celestials also laid the groundwork for
metahumans to proliferate by seeding
special genetic material into other
races so all this dates to the dawn of
homo erectus which is about 1.8 million
years ago on planet Earth so they sort
of rewrite what the original history of
the earth is and where metahumans came
from in what the true purpose of the
Eternals was like the Celestials have
this grand cosmic experiment going on in
the background The Avengers have been
through all these conflicts so naturally
they feel like they're pretty good
people even though sometimes they lose
they get their asses handed to them
their friends die they still end up
winning the day in the end like they
just survived secret Wars after the
beyonders tried to completely destroy
their multiverse
man goes to Olympia finds that all the
Eternals are dead mysteriously wouldn't
it be weird that Marvel is killing all
the Eternals in the comics right before
they introduced them in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in a little while
they find a dead celestial buried deep
in the earth that was killed by Odin in
the ancient Avengers I'll do a video
about them later this week they're
actually pretty cool so remember that
the Celestials created the Eternals and
seeded the earth with life that was
responsible for the proliferation of
humans as well as metahumans so
everything on planet Earth was based on
an experiment that the Celestials were
running while at the same time Loki is
giving the same type of story to Captain
America telling him what really happened
only in a much more sinister way like
he's having a little bit more fun with
it
Icarus reveals that the Celestials true
purpose for the turtles wasn't to
Shepherd humanity what happens is if the
Celestials are tasked by eternity which
is sort of the physical embodiment of
the multiverse to garden eternity like
seed life if there are weeds there
experiments on planets that don't work
out with certain types of life-forms
they come back and they kill it off so
it's been almost a couple million years
since humanoid life has been on planet
Earth now there's a celestial host
that's going to descend and destroy the
planet because Icarus reveals that it
was a failed experiment Loki says the
same thing to Captain America we are
here to call you so because the
Celestials are the agents of the
multiverse it's sort of like the
multiverse saying that planet Earth does
not deserve to exist it's a weed to be
destroyed it's kind of funny watching
Loki try to blow Captain America's mind
so you start to see how that could be a
major threat in Marvel phase four big
celestial level problems we got a little
taste for that with ego the Living
Planet when he said he was going to
terraform the entire universe so that
everything would become a piece of him
only we can remake the universe only we
can take the bridle of the cosmos and
lead it to where it needs to go
you need to readjust the way you process
life everything around us including the
girl everything is temporary we are
forever as an attorney to get boring not
if you have a purpose Peter
[Music]
the only other Celestials we've met
officially in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are Isan the searcher who the
collector shows when he's doing that
flashback explaining the power gem then
also the base that they're inside that
big giant head is the head of a dead
celestial so you could count that as one
two but there are many many more
Celestials and like Loki is telling
Captain America this big story here
while they're at the site of the carcass
of an alpha celestial which is one of
the original Celestials so if you
remember Marvel legacy last year that's
when they first introduced the idea of
the Avengers 1 million BC Odin's
Avengers with like the original version
of the Phoenix the very first Black
Panther the very first star brand like I
said I'll do a video about them later
this week because they're like a whole
separate thing
Marvel is laying the seeds for a very
different looking Marvel Cinematic
Universe in the future
which includes doing a lot of old-school
movies - so like most movies right now
take place in present day we move the
timeline forward there are a couple
exceptions to that like we have Captain
Marvel which is taking place during the
90s we have the original Captain America
movie which took place during World War
two
just prepare for them to explore more
parts of the timeline that we've never
touched before which includes Eternals
in the ancient history of the earth so
remember that there are millions of
years old they've been around since the
dawn of life on the planet so you have
to imagine couple million years for Homo
erectus that eventually homo sapiens
then you have to imagine that humans as
we know them today are only you know
several tens of thousands of years old
so we've only been around for a little
while even though the Eternals and
humanoid life seated by the Celestials
have been around for millions and
millions of years so the really cool
thing that they're teasing in the comics
right now is that essentially it's Earth
defending itself from a giant celestial
host that's come to call it so it's not
fan OHS trying to erase half of all life
it's them trying to erase all of life
like no this is a wasted experiment
humans were never intended to pan out it
would be like the universe telling you
you're trash then sending its celestial
garbage man to come clean you up that's
what they're getting ready for so that
is the bigger threat than Thanos without
going straight to say like Dormammu but
it's just another option in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe for another
really really big threat for the
Avengers in phase four or five and six
it's a little early to know what Kevin
Feige splain is for how they're gonna
plot out the next couple of phases he
said he has like the next 20 or so films
planned out that'll probably change a
little if they get some of the x-men IP
like I would love to see a version of
The Avengers 1 million BC with Phoenix
on the team that would be badass a young
version of Odin the very first Ghost
Rider the very first Black Panther
Phoenix star Brant that looks a lot like
Hulk and then the very first Iron Fist
so just let me know in the comments how
do you want them to incorporate the
Celestials into Marvel phase 4 and phase
5 even if they don't become the
overarching villain and they don't do
something like what they're doing in the
comics right now it feels like it's a
lot of untapped history in the movies
that they'll eventually get to through
the Eternals movie so remember we know
they're doing an Eternals movie we know
that they were created by the Celestials
so if you're gonna do their origin then
you have to do Celestials in some way
what'll happen is is I have a couple
ant-man videos that I'll post in the
next couple of days my full review post
credits Easter eggs all that stuff
should post throughout the weekend so
I'll just update people in that top end
comment on when videos are posting
congratulations to Yanni's you're the
latest giveaway winner please private
message me so I can get your contact
details while you wait for all that you
can click here for my non-spoilery
ant-man in the wasp review and click
here for more new Avengers infinity war
deleted scenes thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]